Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Denise RQ
¿Estudias para un examen?
¿Tratas de hacer más cosas de
las que te permite el tiempo?
El estrés es una sensación que todos
tenemos al ser desafiados o abrumados.
Pero más que solo una emoción,
el estrés es una respuesta física
que viaja por todo el cuerpo.
A corto plazo, el estrés
puede ser ventajoso,
pero cuando se activa con mucha
frecuencia o por demasiado tiempo,
la respuesta primitiva al estrés
no solo cambia tu cerebro
sino que también dańa muchos
otros órganos y células del cuerpo.
La glándula suprarrenal
libera hormonas del estrés,
cortisol, epinefrina, también
conocida como adrenalina,
y norepinefrina.
Conforme viajan estas hormonas
por el torrente sanguíneo,
llegan fácilmente a los vasos
sanguíneos y el corazón.
La adrenalina hace que
el corazón lata más rápido,
eleve la presión arterial, y con
el tiempo provoca hipertensión.
El cortisol puede hacer que el endotelio,
el revestimiento interno
de los vasos sanguíneos,
no funcione con normalidad.
Los científicos saben ahora
que este es un paso temprano
en el desencadenamiento del
proceso de la aterosclerosis
o placa de colesterol
acumulada en las arterias.
Estos cambios aumentan la posibilidad
de ataque cardiaco o derrame cerebral.
Cuando el cerebro detecta el estrés,
activa el sistema nervioso autónomo.
A través de esta red de
conexiones nerviosas,
tu gran cerebro comunica
el estrés a tu entérica,
o sistema nervioso intestinal.
Además de causarte mariposas
en el estómago, esta conexión
cerebro-intestino puede perturbar
las contracciones rítmicas naturales
que mueven los alimentos en el intestino,
que llevan al síndrome
del intestino irritable,
y pueden aumentar la
sensibilidad intestinal al ácido,
haciendo más probable que
sientas ardor de estómago.
A través del sistema nervioso intestinal,
el estrés puede cambiar la composición
y función de las bacterias intestinales,
que pueden afectar a tu salud
digestiva y general.
Hablando de la digestión, el estrés
crónico afecta tu cintura?
Bueno, sí.
El cortisol puede incrementar el apetito.
Se dice que el cuerpo
repone las reservas de energía
con alimentos muy calóricos
y carbohidratos,
haciendo que prefieras alimentos cómodos.
Altos niveles de cortisol pueden hacer
que esas calorías adicionales vayan
a la grasa visceral o de vientre profundo.
Este tipo de grasa no solo hace
más difícil abrochar los pantalones.
Es un órgano que de forma
activa libera hormonas
y químicos del sistema
inmune llamadas citoquinas,
que pueden aumentar el riesgo de
desarrollar enfermedades crónicas,
como enfermedades cardiacas
y resistencia a la insulina.
Mientras tanto, las hormonas del estrés
afectan a las células inmunes.
Inicialmente, ayudan a luchar contra
invasores y sanar después de una lesión,
pero el estrés crónico amortigua
la función de células inmunitarias,
las hace más susceptibles a infecciones,
y reduce la tasa a la que sanas.
¿Quieres vivir una larga vida?
Puede que tengas que
frenar el estrés crónico.
Esto se debe a que incluso se ha
asociado a telómeros acortados,
los extremos de los cromosomas
que miden la edad de una célula.
Los telómeros recubren a los cromosomas
permitiendo que el ADN se copie
cada vez que una célula se divide
sin dańar el código
genético de la célula,
y se acortan en cada división celular.
Si los telómeros son demasiado cortos,
una célula no puede dividirse y muere.
Como si todo eso no fuera suficiente,
el estrés crónico tiene aún más
maneras de sabotear tu salud,
incluyendo acné,
pérdida de cabello,
disfunción sexual,
dolores de cabeza,
tensión muscular,
déficit de atención,
fatiga
e irritabilidad.
¿Qué significa todo esto para ti?
Tu vida siempre estará
bajo situaciones de estrés.
Pero lo que importa a tu
cerebro y a todo tu cuerpo
es la manera de responder a ese estrés.
Si puedes ver esas situaciones como
desafíos que puedes controlar y dominar,
más que como amenazas insuperables,
te irá mejor en el corto plazo
y estarás saludable a largo plazo.